So today I'm going to be talking about the role of CAR-T in double refractory CLL patients
that are ineligible for allogeneic stem cell transplant.
I have no financial disclosures, but for full disclosure, I am the PI for Transcendent Emory.
So just to lay the background, as we know, the introduction of targeted therapies has
changed the treatment landscape for CLL and SLL dramatically.
However, there remains an unmet need to overcome resistance to currently available therapies
in patients with relapsed refractory CLL.
Historically, while allogeneic stem cell transplant has provided a curative option for people
with CLL and SLL, it's oftentimes not an option for many patients due to access, toxicity,
and patient fitness, as this is generally an older population.
So in this hard-to-treat population that's ineligible for stem cell transplants, that's
where CAR-T presents a possible and attractive treatment option.
So for the rest of my talk, I'm going to be talking about the development of CAR-T over
time, and more recently, with the availability of commercial CAR-T in the foreign market.
So I'm going to be talking about the development of CAR-T in the foreign market.
So for patients that were eligible for the study,
after screening, they underwent leukophoresis for the manufacturing of the lysosol.
And after the CAR-T product was finished manufacturing,
they were able to undergo the depletion with Flucide.
Notably, patients were allowed to undergo bridging
while the CAR-T product was being manufactured.
And approximately 76% of patients in the study did undergo some form of bridging.
After lymphodepletion, patients would undergo lysosol infusion,
and then they would undergo disease assessment on day 30 and onward.
Based on the initial data, dose level 2 of 100 million CAR-T cells was selected.
And that's the majority of the patients that you see reported in the TRANSCEND study.
I include down there the primary endpoints, which was the primary endpoint was a complete remission.
And key secondary endpoints, this is not exhaustive,
but it included oral response rates, undetectable MRD status,
PFS, and overall survival.
This also just summarizes what I just said.
And here is, this was later presented in the Lancet by Siddiqui et al. in 2023.
This, the graph on the right shows the patient population,
but it's summarized there on the left.
So even though they had approximately 178 patients that were eligible for the study,
after some patients had to like drop out,
because they were found to be ineligible prior to lymphodepletion,
the total number of treated patients was 117.
The median age for this population was 65.
The median prior lines were five,
including chemo and immunotherapy,
BTK inhibitor exposure and BCL2 inhibitor treatment.
So pretty, pretty heavily pretreated population.
And as I mentioned before,
high risk cytogenetics were present in approximately 83% of patients.
So a pretty high risk population.
Of note, also patients had, approximately 44% of patients had bulky disease.
Given the fact that a BTK inhibitor exposure was one of the inclusion criteria,
it's not surprising that 100% of them were previously exposed.
But for the previous venetoclax exposure population, that was approximately 76%.
Here I share some of the efficacy results, again, also presented back in 2023.
So the complete remission rate was approximately 18%.
And,
what's notable about that population is that as you can see here in the graph,
the duration of response, it's the top green curve.
Those patients actually did surprisingly well.
They, you know, they didn't achieve,
or rather they,
they had a durable benefit to treatment.
And that was also present in the,
in the PFS curve.
So from the secondary outcomes,
overall response rate was 43%.
Undetectable MRD status was 63 in the blood and 15.
59% in the bone marrow.
And one of the key insights is that undetectable MRD status was associated with an improved PFS,
but I don't show that curve here.
The adverse events, primarily, most of the toxicity was hematologic.
So grade three toxicity was notable for neutropenia, anemia, and thrombocytopenia being common.
CRS was very common in any grade, but severe CRS was only present in approximately 9%.
And for ICANs like neurotoxicity similarly while it was common severe toxicity was only 18% of node infections were common or at 17%.
And some of these actually contributed to the mortality rate seen in the study.
But overall, the toxicity profile was pretty manageable.
I don't include the full results here,
but one of the cohorts in the transcend study included adding on the Brutinib in order to see whether or not you could achieve a deeper remission.
And you can see here that,
the complete response was much higher at 45% and the overall response rate was 86%.
So there was some rationale potentially for adding this on and improving responses.
I wanted to just finish up by including some real-world data that was recently presented at ASH 2025,
which essentially in this retrospective study showed that in a population of 30 patients across different sites,
that the best CR rate was much higher than was reported in transcend.
At 60% and the best overall response rate was 83%.
Notably, this population was enriched for patients exposed to protobrutinib.
So this may be potentially reflecting more like real-world practice data.
So just to conclude,
the transcend data is still maturing.
Overall survival data is still also maturing.
It has Lysosol has received contingent FDA approval.
So we're looking to see the data as it matures.
And one other,
kind of hypothetical concern in improving CAR-T outcomes in CLL is that we know that CLL T cells are typically dysfunctional.
But the addition of targeted therapies,
including BTK inhibitors seems to be promising.
So this remains potentially an option for patients that are refractory to BTK inhibitors and BCL2 inhibitors.
All right. Thank you.